[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos this is an
incredible episode i'm not just saying
it it's a little bit shorter than our
usual but jimmy carr the incredible
jimmy carr
ryan seacrest of the uk
somebody told me that katie somebody's
like you don't understand he's huge in
the i know he's huge in the uk but they
had to tell me seacrest before i really
understood because i'm quite quite uh
thick and dumb but he's an an amazing
amazing comedian and an amazing amazing
person and this chat is wonderful uh we
were it was gonna be with uh sweet lady
val co-hosting um but unfortunately she
wasn't feeling well didn't make it but
that means we get randy and jason sklar
my friends as co-host and they are
snipers in a cornfield every time they
talk it's hilarious and wonderful and
every time jimmy talks it's hilarious
wonderful and deeply interesting so i'm
very excited for you guys to hear this
we recorded it as part of the just for
laughs comedy fest in 2022
as i was looking for the date just then
i thought it was 20 20.
thank god it isn't
this episode is brought to us by a
couple uh a new pete's pick which i'm
super excited i've been taking pym chews
for years and they have absolutely 100
changed my life specifically in how i
cope with stress and anxiety and i love
that they are natural and amino acid
based that helps your brain do what it
is designed to do which is help you cope
when you are feeling overwhelmed when i
discovered pym it's called pym because
it's prepare your mind no joke the first
night i took them i felt the difference
almost immediately and ordered not just
one subscriptions for my mother and my
brother because i know that the holmes
family deal with stress i know i do and
anxiety so pym choose help you manage
feelings of stress anxiety and overwhelm
and it's wonderful to know that when
you're feeling worried stressed out as
val and i like to say you have a bee in
your belly you can chew just two of
these delicious naturally citrus
flavored no sugar added chews and in
minutes you start to feel more centered
calm and in control it's literally a
technique i love having it in my
cupboard knowing i can return to myself
uh when i need to when i first tried
them i thought they were too good to be
true but here they are we have a natural
non-addictive and non-psychoactive
solution to one of life's most common
problems i like to take it at the start
of my day in the morning to sort of ease
me into a flow state ease me into the
work that i have to do without a
stressed out feeling and i also take
them at the end of the day when i'm
looking to wind down and melt away the
stress that i accumulated while i was
working how well pym chews are comprised
of proven amino acid complexes and
adaptogens that help your brain
support your brain and your body's
ability to organically support your
ability to manage and tolerate stress
anxiety and overwhelm these specifically
formulated amino acids target your
neurotransmitters specifically the gaba
system a naturally occurring
neurotransmitter that helps the body
manage chronic stress supplying your
body with gaba l-theanine and rhodiola i
hope i'm saying that right i know it
works i don't know how to say it puim is
on a mission to end the stigma
surrounding mental health and to make a
better mood accessible for all
and that weren't enough a percentage of
their profits goes toward mental health
nonprofits including bring change to
mind a wonderful non-profit so it's a
new pete's pick if you have anxiety and
stress in your life and you're looking
for a natural gentle effective way to
give your body the nutrition it needs to
fight off stress
honest to god this is stuff that val and
i swear by and i'm so glad they're uh
sponsoring the podcast thank you pym
check out this promo code
here go to you can pym dot com slash
weird for 15 off pym mood chews that's
youcan pym dot com
weird
the second pete's pick that this episode
is sponsored by is my old friend alpha
brain brought to us by our friends at on
it for the past i don't know six seven
eight years i haven't done anything that
involves my noodle that's my brain uh
without taking two or three alpha brain
15 minutes beforehand helps with memory
helps with focus helps with
concentration if i'm doing a podcast if
i'm doing stand-up if i'm writing a
script or if i'm just going on a date
with val and i want to have full access
to my memory and to my vocabulary and
and my ability to listen and participate
i always take alpha brain it is not a
stimulant it's not like caffeine it's
not an energy drink it's nutrition that
your brain needs it's earth-grown
ingredients that help your brain
function the way it was intended to and
at a peak level
i so wish i knew about alpha brain when
i was in college when it came to
memorizing facts learning new things
reading books all that sort of stuff but
i'm still learning i'm still reading i'm
still growing and when i do i take a few
alpha brain and i retain
so much more than i would without it i
absolutely swear by it i keep it in the
jacket pockets i keep it in the car i
keep it in my travel bags i always
always always have my alpha brain and i
just got some of their new black label
which i'm very excited to try so if you
want to give it a try if you're using
your brain chances are you are go to on
it on nit.com
weird and you'll get 10 off everything
you see on that landing page that's on
it.com
weird and show your support of this show
all right everybody enjoy the brilliant
the wonderful jimmy carr and my friends
the guest co-hosts the sklar brothers
get
into it
we don't have a lot of time and i'd
really like to get to it i invited two
guest hosts i'm gonna bring them out and
then we'll bring out our special guest
would you please welcome the scholar
brothers always delightful hello my
friends
we're not short you're just like seven
feet tall people don't know that about
pete he's seven feet tall you guys have
no idea so i've been hosting shows in
montreal yeah montreal montreal all week
and i was i you know i'm leaving you're
walking through the lobby there's
hundreds of people and you're like all
right
i'm not doing it for that reason there's
no other way out that's right
but i'm like the ego flares up and goes
old homes he's about to get a few pets
i'm ready to glad hand my way over to
the inspiration room ram
i was stopped
this is i will never i won't lie to you
today
three times i was tempted to say four
but the real number is three three times
three times someone stopped me and went
how tall are you yeah
and i was like okay all right come on
that's great and then again how tall are
you three times people asked how tall i
am is that the most impressive thing i
did yeah that's
that's be long
a lot of [__] are long guys
how was pete's show he was really tall
he was so tall for most of the show he
was very sure he was up there really
really up there
how short it well it's i know what it is
it's because every comedian i brought on
stage looked like my toddler
[Laughter]
who's a good comedian who's such a good
comedian
this is why i invited two of the
funniest and nicest people in show
business thank you randy and jason thank
you thank you they're gonna co-host
please don't sit on those riffs we won't
they never do
and please everybody just because we i
my podcast is two hours long and they
were like you have the room for an hour
and i was like how tall are you
do you see how tall i am
wait i deserve at least an hour and a
half do you see how tall i am
do i need to walk through the lobby and
have three more people ask me
i also i was eating at expectations
because i think i have autism i can't i
can't
i can't stop eating at the closest
restaurant
the best
are you saying you're on this is the
worst joke ever i will no i'm gonna
leave i'm gonna leave after the show you
were eating at expectations you think
you have autism do you mean to say that
you're on the spectrum oh
stop it
that's it everybody i'll see you you
gotta break a few eggs to make a comedy
omelette guys
that's the clamp for insta instagram
[Laughter]
i'm so happy you made that joke and i'm
also so happy that our guest is
jimmy carr can you believe it yes
jimmy ko
turn that off youtube's gonna yank the
video
we don't we don't have axl rose money
that's my uh that's my theme tune
welcome to the jungle
we've got fun and games
uh it's great to be here thank you thank
you for doing it on time listener first
time caller
i'm very touched you make john mulaney
look like a hobo sir that's fine
dressed up mullany
[__] stole my look
you are a delight we have we actually
accidentally had lunch today
or breakfast i don't know what you call
it oh yeah we had we had a brunch we had
a brunch okay there it is see even the
way you say that makes me feel elegant
it felt very obvious there yeah
breakfast lunch i don't know what you'd
call it
famously there is a word for that if
only
if only there was a word for it
it's all they serve in expectations
i really feel like you should have had
the jump on this that i they probably
say that at the top of the menu brunch
all day
and yet i was confused but i ran into
you and neil brennan two of my favorite
people and we we had like a pre-podcast
everything you said was so wonderful oh
well thank you very much indeed but
let's let's let the listener decide
let's yeah sure because this let's
manage expectation here expectation
expectation
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm gonna say can we turn jimmy's mic up
just a little bit he's not as also if i
could be ten percent funnier yeah sure
[Laughter]
i mean i worked i don't know what you
pressed but wow i know
it's unbelievable that's so much funnier
by the way that's so much funnier yeah
over ten yeah okay so uh i can bet take
it back to you
it's not fair to the rest of us that's
right
but you are like a champagne flute
became a person
be august yeah it's that vibe isn't it
but bell uses you not beasts
beasts can't handle you with those paws
no sure no one could hold you sure i'm
exactly what you ordered as a british
man that's right
somewhere between mr bean and hugh grant
bullseye
yeah
i had i had a great moment with uh with
hugh grant it's it's a fun story so i
hosted a party in my in my house and uh
i had lots of people that i know hugh
pretty well and my friend brought along
monica lewinsky
and uh so monica's in my kitchen she's a
friend i know her if you haven't seen
her ted talk it's fantastic about being
publicly shamed in the internet age
anyway she's in my kitchen and hugh's
there and i introduce them i say hugh
this is monica monica this is hugh and
hugh grant says oh hello i'm hugh i'm
the other fellatio scandal from 1992.
[Applause]
and then eddie murphy walks in and is
like not so fast
here we go
oh my god did a portal open to another
world yeah he's a very very funny boy
hugh grant he's he's you know he feels
like he's got that thing you know you
meet someone you go yeah it should have
been a comic is that right should make i
know acting and creating your movie
start yeah it should have been a comment
you know who loves hugh grant and you
can tell kumail kumail nanjiani used to
watch all the hugh grant movies in uh
karachi and he was obsessed and when you
my wife and i
uh watched notting hill recently because
we have a lesbian relationship yeah so
well
that explains the hair
this hair definitely makes its own
cheese yes that's true
i don't mean the hair itself i have to
go
but we were watching it and we were like
you can see kumail in his delightful
performance which i would say hold up
holds up let me let me just text him
real quick yeah do it on my phone yeah
that's going to be tricky
who are you texting you're not going to
be able to overcome he doesn't do it no
that's siri you don't have are you
[__] you've got to open the phone
first
please that would have been a song i
know they know enough about me
oh you turned siri off yeah i have no
interest in that can i run a premise by
you
yes here it comes uh-oh why
maybe you are autistic yes
feels like
it feels like it just feels like i don't
know how you feel like his listeners uh
you feel his listeners but it feels to
me like if you're going to ask a
question in a podcast just ask it yeah
look let's finish this conversation at
expectations
god no i was just going to say i've been
doing a bit where i'm like we put a
listening device in our homes alexa
and what we got in exchange was music
pause we already had music
yeah you know what i mean like they were
like we'll give you music and i'm like
we already had that but we're like we'll
make you won't have to do this anymore
and that's very bizarre well what if
that was a joke here you go
uh um i won't know it's the uh the thing
that i had was i don't yell it
i i
the uh you you're all aware of this
thing the audience the the phone
secretly listening to our conversations
yeah you'll be chatting to a friend
about the good old days and then for the
next two weeks you're bombarded with
adverts for anal beads and butt plugs
sure
been there
which by the way they sell those at
expectations they do they do
oh is that it
what do you mean is that the big laugh
is the clue it's over
how long you've been in this business
okay come on let's uh i love that you
laugh like the dolls in toy story four
that's right the scary antique dolls
that was our joke
now listen my movie career i was in
goosebumps toy story 4. i've done a lot
of stuff
i don't know you know i love roasting
we've done a few roasts together so
you're bringing it out of me but
honestly i'm thrilled that you're here
and kind of in the spirit of the podcast
one of the things we mentioned we could
talk about is as you called it the dow
of comedy i'm very interested yeah i
wrote a book um in the in the lockdown
you basically had a choice as a comedian
our managers came to us uh when we had
covered in the lockdown uh and we were
locked away for 18 months couldn't work
they said well you can do a podcast or
you could write a book and i took the
dignified decision
and i i you know i i'm better than this
i'll do a book so sure i wrote a book
and so when the podcast failed you did
the book and
so i did the um can podcast fail yeah
wait was that the title of stay tuned
so i wrote this thing about uh about it
started off as a as a biography and then
it became like a a self-help book uh
basically taking you know that's the
problem with self-help the problem with
eckhart tolle and the power of now is
the people that need it don't read it
because you know if you're drawn to that
kind of thing and it's very earnest and
all the stuff is correct in those books
they're fantastic if you can be bothered
to read them but they don't sweeten the
pill so i thought well i'll kind of take
some of that stuff that i've read of
these that's really helped me
and sort of apply it through comedy to
life because the basic lesson of every
self-help book in the world is the same
premise it's prioritized later over now
that's all they say it it's prioritized
later over now and really i think the
journey of every stand-up comedian is
that we spend so much time no one gets
there quickly everyone's like ten
thousand hours like learning how to
write jokes learning how to do this and
then suddenly it pops but we're just
always kind of looking at the future
and it's a really interesting kind of
you know for young comics sort of it's
just yeah right jokes that's it right
yeah so prioritize it's interesting i
thought you're going to say the opposite
especially after you dropped eckhart
tolle who would say
prioritize now over later well it's any
truth where you find that balance in
life is really interesting of like going
do you have as much fun as you possibly
can today without totally [__] up
tomorrow yeah i love that it's like it's
great but that thing of like go if you
can you there's no such thing as a time
machine right but there kind of is that
but it's time the time machine is only
moving in this direction at this speed
but you can give yourself gifts in the
future you can be
you can have the best stand-up show in
the world in five years time you just
need to work you can you can be thin you
just need to die and exercise you can be
rich you just need to save money it's
like it's that thing of like going you
you get to meet you in 20 years time but
it's not like you don't just appear like
bill and ted's it's just wait around
you're going to be there and who are you
going to be and the idea of kind of
saying that like through comedy i really
i came to it quite late i was about 26
when i started and i just put so much
into it and i kind of think that's the
other great thing that i learned from or
that comedy gave me or taught me it was
like finding your edge in life it might
not be comedy but whatever you do better
than anything else like what's the thing
that you do best and lean into that
because we live in kind of a
a specialist economy right
we live in a specialist economy so you
don't want someone who's like school
teaches you to be
quite good at everything
but then the world doesn't want more c
grades in physics
no one needs that like find the thing
you're good at just lean into that and
specialize and that was the thing that
kind of comedy taught me which i think
is kind of a it's a transferable lesson
yeah what i find interesting well i i
feel like we could have applauded i feel
like we should applaud that though right
so
they weren't sure if he was done yet
yeah i know i i actually that's why i
was trying to give permission because i
was like i want a lot that but we didn't
want to stop you from making another
great point let me ask you this i find
when i talk to people
one of the ways that sometimes i think
people might be misguided is they're
trying to bend
into a specialty the thing that they're
better at anything than anybody else no
no not better than anyone else
right that's a very important
distinction it's the thing that you do
best you don't have to be world class it
at
[Laughter]
like the ten thousand hours thing the
thing that gladwell misses and i love
that book you've read outliers right
do you know that it only took him nine
thousand hours to write
of the premise of the book is well you
do it for 10 000 hours look at the
beatles and they rehearse for that long
and then suddenly they're this fabulous
band because they come together and
comedians all do that we're all on the
road and then it it happens after that
amount of time but it's what could you
stand to do for 10 thousand hours that's
the interesting question there's two
great journeys on life the first is
finding what you want to do and the
second one is doing it and tragically
most people get to do neither they never
get to find that thing that they want to
do the quest but the first thing is
finding the question you kind of need to
know who you are
before you go on the like the superhero
movie kind of thing you need to know who
you are before you go on the quest but
you don't put any that there there's a
little bit of talent i think that like i
think that's the edge that's the leaning
into the thing that you do that is
because there's a mixture of the talent
that you have in getting enjoyment out
of leaning into that talent yeah but the
two great myths i believe in our culture
are
luck and talent
right it's it's like the
but that thing of like the talent myth
is there in our society right you go
it's it's sort of it's talent and hard
work sorry the two myths are talent and
hard work so you look at someone like
michael jordan you go oh my god he's so
naturally gifted right but i tell you
that guy's nothing without hard work
absolutely nothing without hard work and
you look at someone like bill gates and
it's like oh my god he worked so hard he
was in the computer lab 16 hours a day
he worked so hard you go that guy's
nothing without talent it's always a mix
of the two it's always that thing of
like you have to
play the devil's advocate because i
think michael jordan is was built in
such a way that like his height his the
way he was if he hasn't been together if
that guy does the same if he doesn't he
he's an nba journeyman he's not the
greatest of all time like the thing and
i would argue with michael jordan the
interesting thing here is he trained so
hard and put so much into it that it
[__] up the rest of his life like he
couldn't have friends he had to like
play throw quarters against a wall with
a person with the security guard who
wasn't his friend at all to try and
steal someone someone told me a great
story about um this is a real this has
got nothing to do with anything but you
want to hear the story um he's in my
kitchen
this is what we do on podcast he was
he was at the end of my friend's garden
willie my friend lives on a fancy golf
course and uh michael jordan went by and
he was playing with his friends and they
were they were gambling for i think it
was something like ten thousand dollars
a whole 150 for the nine so there was a
lot of money a lot of money and they're
gambling at that level and then his
friends go michael jordan's friends has
been and he's still there for another
day uh ladies got hours so he says to
the the pro golfer he says would you
want to play
and the guy the pro golfer goes yeah
great i'll play and he goes for money
and the pro golfer goes oh no i can't
i can't play for
10 thousand a whole and michael jordan
goes no no it doesn't have to be ten
thousand whole
whatever makes you uncomfortable i will
[Laughter]
it's what he said to his wife too
whatever
whatever makes you uncomfortable
thank god but i think what you're saying
is that
that we have a range this is what i
think we're all kind of saying is that
we all have a range of
the outcomes of what our
sort of pursuits will become what will
the outcome become if you put tons of
work in with mix of talent then you can
be at this level within your range at
the top of your range well i suppose at
its extreme it's like if you have no
aptitude like you can be anything you
want to be in the world it's total
[__] [__] why are we telling kids
that it does you know you'll never be
you guys are not going to be mba
starting work as hard as you want it's
never going to happen so the the
aptitude plus the work and then it's
that thing of going think of yourselves
like michael jordan think of yourselves
like gamblers and say well what's my
largest edge is about your largest
chance of success what's the thing that
you do well i think i've got an angle
here i think i've got the best chance of
succeeding at this thing and then you
push yourself into that can i ask you
the question then
what i run into is a lot of people
tend to think their thing is something
that our culture values fame power money
right but often their thing very well
may not be one of those things well you
know what i mean i've got a theory on
fame
wealth and power which is uh fame has
replaced heaven in a secular world fame
is the land of milk and honey you think
everything's gonna be okay when i'm rich
and famous every day and then you know
read the papers rich and famous people
have the same problems just they don't
have the problem with money or they have
a different problem with money but it
has replaced you have a dream home and
you used to worry about where you would
live then you get a dream home then you
worry it's going to burn down sure and
or something's going wrong with it it's
the it's uh i know a lot of rich people
what's the question with recycling who's
the who's this
who's david lee roth uh referred to his
mansion as a tomb with a view
oh
i love that was that before after he
became a paramedic that was uh why he
became a parent why he became a parent
you know you were aware of the story
david lee roth uh left he was in rock
and roll and he left retrained became a
paramedic in an all-jewish neighborhood
of new york in order to serve
really yeah for two years he was a
parent i can't believe they went back to
rock and roll i can't believe he's an
ambulance company replaced him with
sammy hagar that was
not a cool move
i mean
and then with gary sharon from extreme
that felt extreme i felt a little this
is a day off for old homesie i'll tell
you that right
sorry hold homes no i love you are you
kidding me this is the best day of my
life
yeah it's interesting that thing of like
fame and like what you're going for the
um
it's that thing of like what's success
in life and you know different people
you know you can talk about fame and
fortune obviously a festival like this
is often the thing about montreal and
just for laughs the festival we're at is
people often talk about oh they got a
sitcom deal or they're doing a hbo
special or netflix or whatever but
actually it's the it's the process right
what's the enjoyable thing about comedy
well it's being in a flow state how
often can you be in a flow state so some
people get to do it as their job not
everyone but some people we get to do it
as our job we're in a flow state we're
on stage it's absolutely the most
enjoyable thing in the world to be in a
flow state some people do it as a hobby
they find a sport that they love and
they play tennis or whatever it is and
they just they're in that state and it's
so relaxing and it's important to have
that every week you have to have that in
your life yes and if you can make that
your job i mean you'll never work again
well that's in the movie happiness which
i it's a movie i watch every couple
years it's a documentary they talk about
line cooks get in a flow state and it's
one of the reasons why they enjoy their
work yeah but that is that's kind of my
point is to the people listening
i just those do you understand what i'm
saying the people that bend and they
assume they want to be a movie star when
really maybe they will be probably in
something else the problem with being a
comedian at this festival and look
around people get to be a comedian and
then they try and do other [__]
and i think they're crazy they have the
best job in the world and they go yeah
but now i'm going to be in a sitcom
[__] you should have been an
actor then if you want to be an actor
because you're here here here
hang on a second
don't
pete's a good actor
he doesn't what do you mean he is a good
actor because he pretended not to be
hurt by that that's right
no and he's pretending to be interested
in what you're saying so much no i'm
kidding
he's such a good actor in one movie he
played like he was five foot eight
that's
just great acting
you know it is
the other night we were supposed to do
pete holmes and friends and there was a
fire at the monument theater and so they
had to bring all the canadian uh new
faces over and canceled our show
that our show with pete that we were
going to be on with pete we came there
we were so excited to do it and all
these canadian new faces pete hosted
that show which was great
and to talk about the love of comedy jay
and i just sat next to the stage while
pete did his
instead of just going back and [__]
off back to the hotel we sat and wrote
like tags of jokes yeah four people or
pete off just every time he came off
stage we pitched him tags on his jokes
it was amazing and we should have left
like we should have been gone but
that's i always think that's a really
good test of like when you know the
festival uh and there's you know new
faces and new comics that you haven't
met before and the festival's been going
a couple of days and you ask them what
they've seen and if they tell you they
haven't seen anything they're not going
to make it
you know it's that thing if they've gone
out and they've seen a bunch of shows
and they're into comedy because they
love it great yeah if they love it
they'll be fine because that dean is
going to be hard years but if you love
it who cares it's fine that's absolutely
right the nut the moment when you're at
your comfortable house and you're you
have a set that you're going to go to
and you just don't there's a feeling
inside of you going i don't want to do
this set
but you go and you know that something
special might happen on stage you might
go backstage and hang out with people
that you love and have those moments of
truth
here's the problem it's all about here's
the problem with comedy for me certainly
it's uh work is more fun than fun
you go to work you go this is this is
unbelievable and then you go after
dinner with friends and go ahead
i don't know
it's because you're i don't know i guess
i guess you're nice but
valerie and i just had that i did a set
at the improv and then we went to a
party and i'm only mentioning this
because it makes the story better it was
the cast of ted lasso was at this party
and i couldn't wait to leave i was like
i've already done my cocaine may i leave
my stagecoach wow that's
that's the title of the tell-all
biography that comes out
i've already done my cocaine i've
already done my cocaine that that's my
memoir at the end of life
i already did my cocaine montel williams
is uh montel jordan this is how we do it
and his his memoir will be called that
was how i did that
[Laughter]
also i'm not montel william
that's the
montel williams
let me ask you this backstage you said
something interesting we were talking
about jokes and you said don't you
sometimes feel like the joke already
existed yeah i sometimes get that when
you're writing a joke and it feels like
that the old stories about uh
leonardo da vinci was asked about his uh
was he in your kitchen he was not in my
kitchen but it was the it was the the
famous story about him being asked about
you know david how did you do that and
he just said i just chipped away
everything that wasn't david
as like david said could i have had a
bigger dick
could you have left some of that marble
are you certain that's not david
i'm gonna be standing nude for millions
to save
could you leave a little bit more that
is
hot david
yeah
[Laughter]
i mean
you've got to say hot riff
no he did
he said it but i love that but you've
had this but i think that joke thing of
like sometimes you just go i can't
believe no one's seen it was right there
certainly with you know some of the
wordplay i mean the mind is kind of a
mix of there's some observational stuff
and there's quite a lot of wordplay and
it's layering up stuff so when you're
when you're writing a show you're you
have the bare bones of the joke the
discipline of like trying new jokes all
the time and then there's kind of a
routine that's about something and then
you're kind of you're layering points
with one-liners over the top because joe
writing is quite a rare skill there's
not many people that can write an error
jokes that people want to watch and you
go i want to lean into that deliver i
like the frequency of comedy as well i
like that idea that it's just it should
be sort of you know some of that phrase
laugh a minute you go gee i wouldn't
make a living i laugh i mean you want
you want three loves a minute you want
that kind of you want the audience to
kind of get a bit giddy because
ultimately what we are is drug dealers
yes we're dealing yeah we're dealing in
dopamine endorphins the genius of it
will never they'll never take us alive
is because the drugs are already on the
audience and we're just tickling them
out that's right yeah i mean
but also i would argue that you're set
in addition to all of that underneath
all of that is your perspective is jimmy
carr's perspective on all like tied
together ties the whole thing together
so i mean what i don't know i mean i
never say what i think on stage
but it's i think com comedians leak it's
my big theory on comedians is we leak so
i do an hour of jokes and they're about
the worst things in the world yeah
they're brutal and then somehow people
have a sense oh yeah this guy's probably
probably slightly on the left and pretty
liberal it's like it's weird how people
know who you get a sense of the comedian
yeah i mean the other the other big um
my big theory on comedians is uh big
theory on comedians
okay
you
if you if you meet a comedian if you're
hanging out with comedian ask them which
one of their parents was sick
most comedians i know had to take care
of a sick parent uh either mentally or
physically they had one of their parents
were sick and their job in the household
was vibes and they had to make things
okay and then they lent into that and i
think that
please that true to you pete
i just turned up a face i was genuinely
making for laughs but yeah that's that's
uh [__] right on
you're like anthony jeselnik became dr
phil
it's it's an interesting conversation
because i think you know the festival or
whatever when you meet comics it's like
you could do small talk oh you see any
good shows whatever you get into it
straight away yeah how many parents were
sick yeah
i'm not trying to like
it's not a gotcha moment did you was
that your ex my mother was very
depressed uh i think my whole life and i
you didn't you don't realize as a kid
because you grew up in that household
and you think it's normal to just be in
your dressing gown all day and and she
was incredibly self-medicated with humor
she was incredibly funny
and depressed and it was it was a
wonderful um she was a wonderful person
to be around she didn't like it wasn't
like a a dark atmosphere but she was
clearly um suffering with it and it was
a
it was a she she's kind of the reason i
do this i think in terms of
you're kind of inspired by that the the
magnetism i always make like a
distinction um
with comics as well my other kind of
theory is there's two types of comedians
there's charming and charismatic
and they're very the words have become
conflated in our world right charming
charismatic the same i don't think it is
the same i think it's vastly different
so if you think about obama right
president obama is hilarious
he is hilarious i mean go ahead have you
seen his mom jeans all the way up to the
all the way up with pleats
the uh i can't wait to find out if he's
charming or curious yeah well he's
incredibly charming so he's head to the
side
would be i
i come to you
that's charm i come to you you want to
say yes to him before he's asked the
[__] question it's charm
trump is charisma you know you don't
forget whether you like him or don't
like him you don't like him but
let's be clear but that but he's he
screws me you come to me uh
if you think about um
jennifer aniston
charm personified angelina jolie
charismatic one isn't better than the
other they both get to [__] brad pitt
but
yep but they're very different skills
and i think i think that partly the
thing of like the other thing that
comedy gave to me was you have to know
who you are
in order to kind of to make good on you
know whether you're charming or
charismatic you have to know that know
what you're working with pete they both
get to [__] brad pitt but only one of
them gets to drink his blood
[Laughter]
jolie oh no i was gonna say innocent but
that's what's in smart water
let's not it's so true
[Laughter]
the charisma
christian versus charm i think that is i
don't know which i am well charm by i
mean jesus christ how could you not see
that
well i mean you're you're literally
you're charm personified oh wow
incredibly charming it's like it's it's
almost like a superpower you've just got
this ability to kind of
people feel very very comfortable and
you know the warmth that you project
when you do comedy is it's extraordinary
and in the sitcom the whole thing it's
just it's
i'm right right it's that's very well i
do it's lovely whereas i
yes which are you barely have a human
heart
no i'm i'm charismatic it's a different
it's a different thing but it's
interesting like going one isn't better
than the other it's it's you we're
washing the same side of this we're
washing different sides of the same
elephant yeah i would say you're a
cigarette marketed towards ladies
personified
[Laughter]
after you were so nice
so pete where are you going i don't know
where is he going i don't know he just
got taller he went up on the chair to
get taller a few i've just just give me
a second i'd just like to say a couple
of um uh words about mental slims
look i
it was so nice and so sincere i just
know that that's that i hope that's your
love language we you and i worked on
roasting jokes all the time let i don't
want to not get to it so can we jump a
little bit to god i know you're an
atheist or her atheist uh yeah i think i
think i'm an atheist but i think it's
that thing of um
i think i always think the most
interesting question in life
is what was the last thing you changed
your mind about
that's my favorite question to ask
someone and if they go nothing you just
okay well you've not been thinking
you've just been rearranging your
prejudices
wow you should change your mind about
something very important yeah by the way
every year
and i i am an atheist but i think the um
the the spiritual side and what those
stories give us i think it's got
tremendous bella benefits there's
something in uh myth and legend that's
incredibly important and you know why do
those stories survive why do the
why are those stories like
2 000 years old 3000 years old stories
and they they resonate with us and that
so it's almost kind of leaning i'm not a
religious man but like when you look at
the jungian archetypes and you look at
those those things that just remain in
society i think that's very powerful yes
i i was i wanted to share but but it's
it's
sorry on that on this religious thing i
think uh what do you think about all the
time
what do you think about what do you wake
up thinking about what do you think
about all day what do you check your
phone for all the time that's your god
yeah richard says follow the money what
do you spend your money on too is
another great way to see what you
actually give a [__] about
yeah that's interesting yeah that's
that's an interesting i mean i always
think that's uh
yeah it's a it's interesting it's like
where where where do you actually spend
your time what are you really talking
about that's the other one he says
time much more than money yeah i think
time is the only thing i would i would
agree with that and honestly i hope
that's true because i spend a lot more
time
trying to delight people than i do
giving them money
right
great i'm not saying i don't give people
money but i do this a lot and i hope
this is of service in some way yeah i
think i think it is i think it's a it's
a nice thing but it's interesting like
where you choose to spend that time all
we have is
uh
you know that the terrifying truth is uh
[Music]
the world is a thing that we make and we
could just as easily make it a different
way and that you know that's the world
but also our individual lives you know
people are constantly saying especially
like over breakfast today we were
chatting about the state of the world
and how terrible it is right and you you
can only brunch sorry
that's right
uh how tall are you getting exactly
right
get it exactly right please
but that thing of light just taking
responsibility for your bit of it seems
to be a very worthwhile thing of like
just going well i'll just control i can
control this bit and make it better
that's that i i'm obsessed with a
teacher named rupert spyro who's british
and uh you should know him and uh you
should be in your kitchen he says he
said when he was seven years old he said
when he was seven years old
he said to his parents i think this is
god's dream and it's our job to make it
as nice of a dream as possible whether
or not you believe in that is literally
being true i think that's sort of what
you're getting at like we can change it
we can make it however we want it to be
you know the john lennon story tell me
john when he was i think he was seven he
was in school and they said what do you
want to be when you grow up
and john lennon said happy
and the teacher said i don't think you
understand the question the uh the
question and john lynn said i don't
think you do
wow
that's
incredible so so i'm going to tell you a
tiny story about my son about ringo
stein
[Laughter]
so so this it's about how you choose to
define you're talking about how you
define something so my son in a very
funny way the other day said we drove by
a restaurant he said i have so much
nostalgia for that place and i was like
the place we ate at last week
i said i don't think you understand what
nostalgia means
and he looked at me and he said remember
when you said that uh he did he did
which i thought was funny but then i was
like oh wait why am i telling him
what nostalgia is why am i trying to
define for this person
what this
ethereal concept that we really can't
touch is what i think i think happiness
is expectations exceeded
did you say expectation
you did
we have a winner i heard that i heard
that no but you're right but i think
it's it's that thing of like why is new
year's terrible right new year's is
terrible always well because the
expectation is this is going to be the
best night of the year it's going to be
huge and there's just a night out and if
you go out on a tuesday and you have
drinks with people from work and you end
up at a club it's like this night is
incredible birthdays i feel the same
about birthdays often the pressure uh
it's just too much i feel the same about
comedy i don't want the fanfare i don't
want to be brought up as the greatest
stuff it's like actually let's go in
being like let's see how this goes
instead of i don't want to do new year's
eve comedy literally and metaphorically
yeah
well tell me when i when we talked
briefly in the lobby about
atheism you said i'm interested in
science and and then you know what you
said because can i load you even more
you said what is science studying and we
had a nice little bond where i was like
we're having the exact same conversation
well i think some people sort of you
know if they say they're an atheist
they'll say i believe in science and you
you sort of go
your next question should always be
what's an isotope
because that's gonna they're gonna go
okay i guess i'm going on faith as well
and the illusion that there isn't any
faith involved in science is slightly
because even a sp even a scientist is
not a specialist in all science so you
go okay so there's there's observable
fact and we're following that and it's
but there's there's kind of a there's a
mystery to it as well physics at a very
high level there's a mystery and there's
a magic and a wonder and i think i get
the same kind of um
wonder that i used to get from religion
i was raised catholic i get that same
kind of wonder but you're you know if
you watch like brian cox is this
incredible
astrophysicist in the uk you watch one
of those documentaries about the solar
system and you think wow
it's incredible yeah
it's it's it's fascinating let me try
and remember what i was just gonna say
because i was listening so hard i
dropped it
i will take a minute this is the paul's
point well now why don't we do an advert
for foursquare that's normally what
happens on a podcast sure that feels
appropriate
what's happening weirdos lately i've
been listening to a lot of audiobooks uh
i'm about to have father greg boyle on
the podcast i've been listening to his
incredible book tattoos on the heart and
it has been great one reason it's been
great is because i use my raycon
wireless earbuds to do it you heard
raycon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever with optimized
gel tips for the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds are so comfortable and
they will not budge even on the
treadmill these guys stay in place trust
me raycon gives you eight hours of play
time and a 32 hour hour battery life
raycons are also priced just right you
get high quality audio at half the price
of other premium audio
brands blands
audio brands it's no wonder raycon's
everyday earbuds have over 50 000
five-star reviews they have three
customizable sound profiles earbud tap
functionality uh functions i guess i
could just say noise isolation and
awareness mode so go to buy raycon dot
com slash weirdo note that it's not
weird it's weirdo by raycon dot com
slash weirdo today to get 15 off your
raycon order that's by raycon dot com
slash weirdo to score 15 off by
r-a-y-c-o-n dot com slash weirdo and
show your support of the show it's also
brought to us this episode by our
friends at dad grass this has to be the
pete's pick that i enjoyed i'm gonna say
10 times more than i even thought that i
would these are bringing back dad grass
you probably see him in some of the
cooler shops around the neighborhood if
you're like me
it's bringing back the chill casual
smoke and i'm loving it chill out all
summer long with dad grass because it's
too nice to be couch locked they'll
mellow you out while keeping your head
clear and ease away the stress of the
day dad grass is legal organic hemp that
relaxes your body and mellows your mind
dad grass cbd products are made with a
100 organic camp that's easy to dose and
the effects come on smooth they offer a
variety of products and their token from
their tokens smokable pre-rolled joints
that's what i have as well as their hemp
flour and variety of cbd tincture drops
which i also have and love this means
you can enjoy the effects of cbd while
keeping a clear head and i don't know i
i'm not big into different things that
people are doing at parties but i love
bringing my pack of dad grass to a party
it keeps me clear while melting away
stress and also frankly gives me
something to do at the party uh with my
hands like uh like will ferrell what do
i do with my hands
and dad products are federally legal for
ages 18 and over and ships right to your
door anywhere in the u.s so go to
dadgrass.com weird to check out their
products whether you're looking for a
new buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favorite dad grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood and right now dad grass is
offering weirdos 20 off your first order
when you go to dadgrass.com weird go to
dadgrass.com
weird for 20 off your first order that's
weird sincerely been enjoying those
quite a bit something wonderful to sit
on the porch with at the end of the day
last but not least guys it's time to
bring that summer heat into the bedroom
you know what i'm talking about
the temperatures aren't the only thing
that's rising this summer that's right
this episode is brought to you by
it's sponsored by blue chew
guys confidence can take you far in life
it can also help in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate and that's where blue chew
comes in blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredient as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them anytime day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever the opportunity arises
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive a your
prescription within days the best part
the whole thing is done online that
means no more visits to the doctor no
awkward conversations and no waiting in
line at the pharmacy blue chews tablets
are made in the usa and prepared and
shipped direct to your door in a
discreet package with bluetooth men
everywhere excited to see the postman
because your packages arrive your
package has indeed arrived they always
say first impressions are important but
what about lasting impressions time to
get off the couch back to work and if
your tool needs an upgrade head to
bluechew.com women say there's nothing
sexier than confidence and blue chew can
help you give you confidence where it
counts so if you could benefit from
extra confidence where when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal for weirdos try blue chew
free when you use promo code weird at
checkout just pay five bucks shipping
that's bluechew.com
promo code weird to receive your first
month free visit bluechew.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast all right enjoy the rest of the
show
what are we studying
so
let me let me so i my wife's brother is
a worked at the at the cern which was a
huge particle accelerator
in um in geneva that tried to recreate
the conditions of the world before the
big bang and smash particles together to
figure out there was an equal amount of
matter and anti-matter in the world and
now there is no anti-matter where did it
go and that was the experiment they were
trying to do but it's a very scientific
experiment you're smashing particles
around a two-mile loop underground
but there is all this mystery like they
don't that well well i was actually what
i was getting yeah we talked about that
[Music]
i was gonna say the world view of there
are no miracles is predicated on one
pretty big [__] miracle that's what i
wanted to say
well people are very interested in the
big bang you know the big bang was
originally a negative term
what do you mean it was someone else
someone came up with the theory of the
big bang uh and it was called like the
origination theory or the uh uh the the
event theory and another scientist who
didn't like it called it the big bang
theory because he was trying to dumb
down the idea going the big bang theory
for [__] idiots
and and it was you know so that that
became popular i'm not really interested
in the big bang i'm interested in four
minutes before that what was going on
right a minute before that what was
happening is is a really interesting
like and no one seems to have much of a
view i was i mean it's it's weird you
can kind of understand these things for
i get glimpses of physics when someone
explains it to me i can kind of grasp it
for a second and then it just it's like
quicksilver yeah i remember i went to a
lecture um stephen hawking was at my
college and he gave a lecture on time
travel and i got it and i i was like
afterwards i was so excited and i was
chatting to my friend henry and
uh
go on
go on if only i don't [__] go back in
time to when you understood it that's
right
yeah i think that's brilliant i wanna
this is something i've said on the
podcast before but one to talk to about
an isotope and working on faith i also
say that nothing doesn't exist going
back to the big thing bang theory yeah
either something god a word for
something we don't understand and can't
photograph and can't touch and can't see
uh that either god erupted that word
that placeholder erupted into the bang
bang or it was nothing and i'm like but
nothing doesn't exist we don't have any
nothing we have empty space but it's
filled with the same everything that you
are yeah i mean the extraordinary thing
is it's mostly nothing
but that if you think about what an atom
is it's mostly nothing that's right yeah
i've seen a couple of acts like that
are you why are you looking at us
there's such a weird look over and just
say that and look at both of us
he looked right through us
it's because there's nothing there
but
dead over
what's right when you die it's just
completely over are you open uh i i i
like to say
i have to do this thing i do a lot
weirdly i'm quite drawn to grief as a as
a thing i've had friends guy my mother
died um
and
i think you died twice you die when you
die and you die again the last time
someone says your name
i like talking to people about their
dead relatives and that thing of going i
think you do live on but it's it's the
it's what you bring children are a
message we send to a future we shall not
see
that's it right yeah that's why people
have kids because it's an existential uh
crisis and they go well i'm just gonna
i'll take care of this one and that will
go forward
rupert spires said the same thing about
if they're again using god as a
placeholder like why will the universe
it's in the same way why have a baby
it's just it's a loving impulse it
wasn't as
calculated necessarily as like oh i
don't know be that's no no do that and
it's more like out of love this
willed itself yeah i mean it's it's
interesting that for 2000 years for the
whole of uh time every song every piece
of art was about god and what 50 years
ago we switched it up and we said every
song's going to be about love and are we
talking about the same thing
and that seems to be fairly i mean you
know
every rock and roll song is now is about
love and whether it's romantic love or
love or whatever it seems that they're
sort of talking about the same thing i
think being very open to
other people doing their thing i mean i
think most most most comments are quite
libertarian and they're like oh you're
you're muslim you're hindu great
whatever great do you think
well i was just going to jump in
you said the same thing love and i'm
getting this from richard rohr but love
doesn't just mean a good feeling love is
this
almost excessively liberal yes it's the
backdrop upon which all of this is
written the horrors and the joy and the
beauty and the loss and the grief and
the suffering and the pain we don't even
like it really but it's so spacious we
won't be able to hold it in our minds
but we can become it you can quiet down
yourself enough and actually be
that yes but it doesn't just mean a good
feeling and i love your car well i think
the verb not a noun is the kind of
simplistic view i like it you know it's
a love is a verb not on noun i think
it's a i think it's a massive attack
lyric also so that's right i would say
god has a verb as well it's the forward
undulation of everything yeah i mean
yeah i think it's acceptable you're
talking i thought it was a comedy
podcast yeah
dick and balls wait wait wait
all of our phones are listening so
dildos butt only dildos
big
thick butt only dildos enjoy those ads
for the next week on your instagram when
butt onlydildos.com reaches out
how can you specify its butt only um you
just
i just just a simple labeling system is
really the way to go
[Music]
oh is that a rhetorical question i'm
sorry no it's like having a kosher
kitchen these weeks
these we clean over here um
thank you victor jews i don't know
what's happening here well it's the same
with the dildos one goes for milk and
one goes for me all right
well you have children i go yeah i've
got i've got children can i just ask you
to refresh something we had a very
interesting conversation at breakfast
something that i think about a lot
yeah is this by the way when we were
talking about nostalgia i was like one
of the keys to happiness is having
nostalgia for the present oh do you
remember you remember when he said yeah
i did you were so tall how tall is this
guy like three times in the lobby
it's a great moment yeah not too
appreciated
i don't know if nostalgia is what it
used to be
you long for the days when it i used to
like it more that's right and you long
for those days um would you reheat just
for these wonderful people and the
people listening a little bit we were
talking about
you're optimistic a little bit and i
like hope and i am optimistic
about um we're talking about uh stephen
pinker's book enlightenment now which is
a fabulous book by a polymath and
linguist about how by any metric you
choose the world is a better place now
than it was 50 years ago 20 years ago 10
years ago now this book was written four
years ago and
that's not so good that's a point he
made not not so great just recently
but things are you know things are kind
of getting better and it's it's um
it's difficult it's a difficult point to
make because i think a lot of people
well immediately that puts their back up
and they go well you don't know what
struggle we're going through right now
and there's so many struggles
going on but the world is it's in better
shape than it was he's at a high
altitude
he's talking about the planet yeah he's
talking about the planet and i think we
all have you know we're all concerned
for
so many different things going on at the
same time but you go it's getting better
we're moving in the right direction and
there will be
gay marriage in saudi arabia now we
probably won't live to see it
but if we're moving on a trajectory
where there's more uh liberty and
freedom and um goodness it's with
humanity seems to be getting better and
you i believe
that we'll move in that direction yeah
that things will get better and i know
you're not a scientist because neither
of us know what an isotope is but what
did you hear about the i overheard you
say i really wanted to jump in but i was
talking to laura he said i think the
environment will figure it out and i
just was like what i like this well i
hope so i mean there's there's a lot of
i mean i don't know i mean a lot of
people would say well you're being crazy
i mean people don't seem to want to stop
consuming so
but and yet we we care about the
environment want things to be better so
for me it's the you know i'm a big
advocate for nuclear i'm a big advocate
i mean and that's a 20-year solution
like and even if we push the button on
it today it would take so long and
believe me i'm not in charge but that
strikes me as a as an incredi like the
technology solution i sort of believe in
that there's there's enough there and we
you know we came across that technology
really by accident really i mean there's
there's
huh nuclear nuclear yeah i mean that
wouldn't really have happened unless
archduke franz ferdinand had been shot i
love that van
perfect
but that i'm quite i'm quite like i'm
like i i'm fairly i try and be i think
the other thing is like my other kind of
thing in life i think disposition is
more important than position
right that's that's a pretty good rule
for life
how you are your your base state is more
important than where you are
and
doing comedy puts you in a place like
the gift that comedy gives you is like
you're looking through rose tinted
glasses you're looking at everything for
the funny side for the joke and it's a
very and why are people drawn to your
podcast to going to see comedy shows to
watching netflix specials to coming out
to shows they want to feel happy and
light and up and common like comedy is
kind of and and how do you change your
disposition
like is your disposition solid state are
you born a certain way and i guess i'm
just a miserable person or can you
change that now if you can't change it
just
i guess we'd all give up it is what it
is i think you can change your
disposition
slowly over time it's either you change
that or you change the world
much easier to change your disposition
that's interesting i actually think
that's another thing and i'd love to
hear you talk about this that you offer
as a performer you talked about we write
jokes we're drug dealers but i think
there's a solidarity thing too when i
see you delighting in your shadow and
sharing it and being naughty right
i go well [__] man i have like five
thoughts this morning we we don't
control what's going on up here and
things come out and when i see you
being cheeky or whatever being a rascal
i feel less alone wouldn't you say i
mean that's what we're doing up here
we're going that's right we don't know
what's going on i'm afraid of the world
ending yeah and we're together i always
say this but like the end of avatar
we're we're bodies in a room or you're
listening in your car or whatever it is
and you go like it's not just me i can't
say but i think that's the we were
talking about the two books that i love
and i can't remember the authors but
there's a book called tribe yep and
there's a book called selfie
and if you read them sort of together
they're i mean it's absolutely sort of
fantastic but we were for the longest
time
in tribes we would live with between 60
and 80 people and that would those would
be our people for the longest time
that's how humans were
and now we're a little bit disconnected
and we'll look and the reason why why a
podcast popular well because it's
conversation we're gathered around the
fire we're talking and it's why do you
come out to a comedy show and laugh
together well it's a social thing you're
30 times more likely to laugh at a
comedy show when you come and see it
live than when you watch it on a screen
oh wow i apologize to netflix if they're
listening i still want a deal
but you are you're much more likely to
it's a social noise you know if you're
listening to this in your car
you know you're probably not laughing
along with the audience that are in the
room
you know we're getting quite a few
laughs in the room but you're just
listening to the podcast yeah that's
good it's funny point but you're not
laughing it's a social thing that we do
we don't consciously think i'm gonna
laugh so that other people know that i
got the joke it's it's just it's
subconscious yeah and it's a and you
release the endorphins and it feels
wonderful and and connecting to other
people that's the it's one of the few
things that are left that feels like
it's the group
the group mentality the group all does
this and functions as like the audience
is like a giant amoeba yeah in many ways
and it functions you get on stage and
you sort of assess as comedians all
right what are we working with here but
after after like especially after covet
after two years of being locked down and
people coming out to shows and you go
your life is a screen now
you wake up and check your phone and
then your sat nav on the way to work and
then you sit in front of a computer and
then when you get home you go i've got
to relax i'll look at the screen
yeah it's green screen screen screen so
you want to go out and feel like you're
it's nice to be in a crowd it's nice to
go i like sitting in a comedy show and
watching with the other people you were
sort of saying that it almost explains
why fame is so alluring do you remember
saying that yeah would you explain what
the the the idea of tribe
it's more normal to be famous what
strange goes yeah that's my my theory
would be being famous is the
is the normal way to be
being famous it's like it's like being
living in a village being famous
internationally it's like living in a
village but you've got alzheimer's did
you have to point out that i'm not
famous in london yeah
internationally yeah hold on pete
you wouldn't understand this yeah but
that's that thing of mine
let's just say that that thing of being
um being being recognized is the normal
thing seeing a stranger would be the
unusual thing for the longest time
and now we've just we've kind of we've
said all the norms just walk down the
street and you don't know anyone and
that kind of isn't the norm it's a it's
a strange kind of trick that we played
on ourselves but we're meant to be
in groups and that's where you feel so
comfortable with with other people
around
i i think that's brilliant i david
letterman said it in his charlie rose
interview where he said being famous
turns it into a small town and i was
like that's that is what i enjoy about
it i'm an anxious person i can i can be
afraid i can be socially awkward but
when you go in and somebody comes up
like at this fest it's happening
constantly how tall are you that's right
how tall are you i actually wasn't doing
a joke but like why even having you guys
here
and feeling very safe in my i know
lizard brain is overused but in my
lizard brain i'm like i'm safe you're
smiling you're looking at me you also
know you're safe i would add to your
thing about amoeba
i'm in the amoeba too you know we are
part of so so not all performers do that
though some performers go like i refuse
to enter the amoeba but some go like
let's all well here's here's the thing
charm and charisma yeah yeah interesting
bring the amoeba to me jimmy carr says
yeah or but i but i actually wasn't
saying you don't get in the amiibo but
that's very interesting i believe if you
for the
agnostic or someone who doesn't believe
in god i always find those moments where
a collective does something together
one of those inexplicable
divine
moments so a room full of laughter a
moment where everyone's like
in a store you know the moment well not
to not to make pete feel insecure and
significant less successful but
when you but when you bear with me when
you tour the world as i do sure
tell us about that no but no i just i
think no i'm just saying this because i
think people find it interesting when
you do like 40 plus countries globally
you do
the thing you notice is like it's
incredible how people are the same it
makes you really believe in humanity
because you could do like a a tiny show
50 people or 10 000 people and they
laugh at the same points for the same
length of time you could do a show in
iceland in south africa melbourne
australia tokyo wherever you want to go
in the world people are the same it's
extraordinary that how we're we're the
same and it makes you kind of go oh this
is maybe things will be okay no matter
where you go jimmy some of the audience
will just be heads in your freezer
that's just a good feeling
big swing yeah
i take it's like we have the dvd
commentary on
and with the subtitles on you just said
i love you pete thanks for having me
just with a look let i know let me let
me we will wrap up that because i feel
you're you're a brilliant guest and i
love this was great i didn't feel like
it was short at all
yeah
let's ask wait
just a couple more
very very uh they can be as long or as
short as you'd like but these are the
questions i like to ask um anything in
your life ever happened that you can't
explain that's sort of an umbrella for
like things like a ufo or a ghost or
a psychic knew the name of your dog when
you were eight or anything like that the
weird stuff
uh i i would honestly i have um a
recurring i don't know whether you would
say it's a psychological
issue but i slightly i feel like i may
have had some kind of accident when i'm
26 when i was 26
and i'm in a
hospital bed
and there's a tv on in the corner
and i think the people on the tv are my
friends
because i feel like i'm sort of living
in a weird dream world
where i get to travel the
world doing comedy and i'm around all
these funny people all the time and i'm
on stage in front of thousands and it
feels like
it feels unbelievable to me yeah that
you feel like your life is so surreal
that really feels like is this like is
it twilight zone is this real am i gonna
wake up yeah
it's it's great i mean it's great i'm
incredibly i try that kind of gratitude
thing i try and just
center that try and be as grateful as
you can or that it just makes life
better just being grateful but also i'm
an incredibly privileged guy such a
privileged life yeah that's beautiful i
love that what about have you ever
almost died
uh
yeah
would you care would i care if i died no
would you care
feels like feels like you were saying we
wouldn't care but would you care
we could do this right now that'll only
be the first time he died the last time
would be the last time we say his name
so i don't it doesn't it the problem
with the story is it doesn't sound real
i could tell the story but it doesn't
sound real i was in key west once and we
were swimming on the reef and we got
myself and my friend henry and we got
chased by a shark and i nearly got eaten
by a shark but i'm gonna need more when
did you first see the shark
and it's henry winkler we all know but
like
you're with henry winkler hank and he
goes hey i think there's a shark over
here
no that's when he jumped it
and we have to go to a gala
get out of here give it up for the scarf
brothers we got to go to a gala jimmy
and i are going to finish thank you love
you jake i love you ryan bye bye
i gotta say yeah i got the thing the
thing i love about your podcast is you
invite two members of the audience up on
stage
no i it really is
well really it's the same member twice
but yeah
they walked out the wrong door
they're so committed to comedy they
[__] that up
those guys couldn't even leave correctly
honestly so great aren't they i was like
i'll bring the scars and i was like
it'll give jimmy something to work with
oh he's
they're a delight they're an absolute
delight i i completely agree they make
me happy so who saw the shark first
uh we were we were kind of snorkeling oh
that story still um where we were
with these kind of baby sharks like
these little sharks all day and you get
very kind of blase and then we sought
another baby shark but it was far away i
don't know if you know how perspective
works
so it was far away and it was small but
then when it got closer i'll slow down
it
it turned out it was quite a big shark
it's like a huge [__] thing and then
it was it was obviously they're
territorial or whatever so we didn't
know at the time but it was you know
swimming towards us and we turned around
and literally
like the old joke i had the feeling of
going well i don't need to be out
swimmer shark
i just have to out swim henry
and
and so and we we swam a little bit
and we got up on fire coral i don't know
if you're aware of how fire coral got
its name
but it's not great to stand on
and we and we waited we tried to get the
boat to come over to us and so we
climbed over the fire coral bit and we
got on the boat on the other side we got
on the boat and we're like white as a
sheet and and kind of a bit panicked and
we got in the boat and the guys were
just laughing at us
going
just reef sharks what are you
it's just a reef shot man they're not
going to hurt you it's just a resharp
relax and we went like a gray with a
with a black tip
and they went oh
oh oh
everyone else out the water
it was like a really it was a real kind
of it was a yeah it was it was it was
interesting uh yeah interesting i think
i was
i wasn't bored
that's one of the best stories of all
time that i had to pry out of you do you
ever and it had punchlines
do you ever do you ever get that thing
on a plane when there's turbulence on a
plane
oh wait so if there's turbulence on a
plane and you think oh we might go down
i think it's a really good test
in life tell me would you be okay
would you be okay dying because i i
think the greatest gift and i've had a
couple of friends do it and it's
magnificent if you can to die well
that's an incredible gift to give your
friends yeah it's it's it's it's so i
had a friend that died and and was just
extraordinary sat me down we went out we
we went and got um
he's he was a writer called a.a gill he
wrote this incredible book if anyone's
ever suffered with uh
um
addiction issues there's a book called
poor me
p-o-u-r-me which is his autobiography
the guy who wrote about addiction and
his name is a.a
gil yeah
but that's
that yeah
[Applause]
but that that's the that oh that was a
joke it was a adrian uh his his uh that
was his middle name was a but he
he went under a a gill after he got into
the program i see and he we had he died
so well and you you we went on the last
we knew it was the last time we were
seeing each other so my other friend
does a tv show and we were going up to
see him and for various reasons i had to
go on a helicopter so
i we went up on the helicopter so we got
in the back of the helicopter and
there's a guy from the show in the front
and the the the driver they call them
pilots
uh
i'll say and me and adrian are in the
back and i'm aware he's he's gonna die
soon and we're aware this is the last
time we're gonna see each other and so
we sit in the back of the helicopter and
he tells me
about life he tells me about um what's
the great thing he shared uh keep your
side of the road clean
if you're dealing with someone in your
life that's difficult uh keep your side
of the road clean
that's all i've i've had an issue with
narcissists in my life
and that's the thing where if someone's
if you have a narcissist in your life
they have the disease and you have the
symptom
but just you have to keep your side
clean and we had this incredible
conversation he was and he knew he was
gonna die and asked him all the
questions that you would ask and uh it
was beautiful and we finished the
conversation and the helicopter landed
and
the we got out the helicopter and the
pilot and the guy from the tv show were
just
in tears we're just like ruined by it
wow
yeah [__] [__]
[Laughter]
jimmy carr everybody i know how to host
the show
jimmy carr what a night
everybody jimmy would you say keep it
crispy it's how we end thank you very
much great keep it crispy keep it crispy
thank you everybody thanks for coming
the show montreal bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]